she was one of the longest-running
ruling monarchs in the history of you
know of molix she ruled over an
incredibly complex and difficult nation
country she was obviously a completely
remarkable extraordinary woman so you
know it's like where do you start and
also at a time
in the 18th century the 18th century in
Europe in general was that extraordinary
era I find the 18th century very
beautiful I love the clothes of the 18th
century I love the architecture of the
18th century and although it's not that
far away in time it's all it's very very
alien to how we are now so there were
many reasons Jason you playing catherine
the great's
love interest at this period of her life
which is towards the end of her reign
the latter part of her reign and it's
quite interesting because your character
Grigory Potemkin is a powerful
successful army man and this series
really messes with gender stereotypes in
terms of Catherine the Great is in
charge you are very much lovestruck and
on the back foot here I mean she's the
center of the universe and she's
incredibly attractive you know not just
as a female but because of who she is
because of what she represents and that
everything revolves in and out of her
and of course there's personal ambition
is that I mean he only becomes what he
is through her she quite rightly reminds
him moment she had quite a formidable
reputation Catherine they're great not
just as a ruler but her private life as
well she was in essence slut-shamed by
Frederick the Great and Frederick was
her big art her archenemy and he was
misogynist he couldn't stand the fact
that there was a woman ruling incredibly
successfully yes she was sexual she was
a serial monogamist I think she enjoyed
sex
but yes this attack on her it's why
Elizabeth the first understood this and
said I am the Virgin Queen so that you
know couldn't she couldn't be attacked
on that level do you think history in
that respect will be kinder to women
figures in current history you know just
this past week we're talking about the
likes of gina miller baroness hale a
greta tunberg on what she's doing do you
think the history books will write those
characters more reflective of what
they're doing
yes do you leave me stuck getting female
history writers - yeah exactly
a lot of the books are still written by
men because you know Kathryn did what
she did and then she was wiped out of
history not wiped out but she was and so
it's pretend when yes you know it
depends what happens after and and
things change and and we should be very
wary because as much as we think things
go like this they don't they often go
like that and and you know what's
happening in certain parts of America
for example against women now is
terrifying it's really really terrifying
so I we shouldn't be too comfortable and
think oh it's all gonna just get better
and better it doesn't necessarily know
so we should be aware if you know what I
hold in my hand absolute power
those in power
to be criminal not only good-looking but
clever to another theme in a series is
absolute power there is again another
wonderful line with Catherine the Great
says do you see what's in my hand
absolute power and and that's very
topical at the moment with what's going
on in the UK and the responsibility that
comes with great power
how does Catherine the Great deal with
that and what has it taught you about
having absolute power you know I have I
can't imagine what it's like I mean you
what none of us really can imagine know
what that that level of responsibility
and there's a tyrannical element yes
that's right exactly and it's the only
way to to survive and and if you feel
that you need to survive because that's
the that's the best thing for your
country but at the same time you have to
take on this tyrannical aspect of it you
know our political situation now is so
different people can be elected out of
Parliament thank God you know like they
take their own responsibility for their
vote you know in in terms of Education
in terms of like you know I think
democracy is is under attack now though
I there's a just a feeling I get that
democracy is wobbling it probably does
need to change but you know I think it's
a dangerous moment in democracy right
now
[Music]